normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government
Nashville school shooter Audrey ha's
Manifesto leaked trans murderer vowed to
kill privileged white kids at Covenant
School Steven Crowder leaked photos of
the manifesto on Twitter and his podcast
Nashville PD has refused to release the
information despite media requests hail
28 shot and killed six people including
three young kids I believe they were all
under the age of nine on March 23rd she
was shot dead by police within 14
minutes of launching the detch now the
big story with this uh release is
information about the motivations it
would seem that from what we have so far
the motivation was anti-white hatred
there are some reports that the full
Manifesto the full notebook is actually
it actually contains way more and some
people are saying actually the full
thing shows this individual hated
everybody but if that were true they
would need to release this to the public
now I don't know that's going to happen
but perhaps for whatever reason this got
leaked it was to try and force the
release of the rest of it which I kind
of don't know if that makes sense
because whoever leaked it could have
just leaked the rest we don't know
exactly why only these select Pages were
released and I got to be honest I'm also
not convinced there is anymore that may
be an excuse where someone's trying to
downplay what this individual uh uh had
actually been motivated by we have this
from the post-millennial local media
Outlet confirms Nashville trans School
shooters anti-white Manifesto pages are
authentic and then we have of course an
investig is currently underway after
release of alleged Covenant Shooters
writings Nashville mayor says so it's
confirmed now I believe we have multiple
reporters confirming this that uh the
individual was motivated by anti-white
hatred and now all of a sudden we're
starting to see these videos pop up
people are basically and they've been do
this for a while but they're pulling up
they're Bas they're making montages of
all of the insane college professor and
univers University rhetoric around
violence targeting white people and
there was one that I saw on Twitter
that's so shocking and insane it's no
wonder people are being radicalized by
this people are also calling out Joe
Biden who has made numerous speeches
about the problems and dangers of white
supremacy now you can you can certainly
argue that people are allowed to
criticize and condemn white supremacy of
course they are but when these
universities and media Outlets claim
that Simply Having a family is white
supremacy you can see how this starts
the rhetoric starts getting crazy now I
guess the questions are was the FBI and
the and and were the police withholding
this intentionally because of what it
contained or is is something else going
on yeah it's hard to say I mean there's
a line in particular from from the one
of the photograph pages that says you
know i' I've been wanting to do this for
a long time I'm excited uh I almost got
caught I believe it's they say the
summer of 2021 and so we we have to
wonder who why why does this person feel
that way there was reporting that Audrey
halil had been um you know under her
parents care to a certain level that
there were emotional and psychological
issues already known to at least her
family um but this to me implies
something bigger than just you know
people were concerned about my behavior
which implies that there's more to the
writings than just the three pages I
mean if she's been planning this thing
for a couple years or had issues for a
couple years and she wrote about how
excited for the past two weeks that
she's been so I bet she was writing
every day for the two weeks doing and
and there's a there there's also report
there may be a 14-minute video yeah I
wouldn't be surprised I mean Audrey Hale
also reached out to people right before
I'm sorry 10-minute video I got wrong uh
you know if I I approve uh it's okay I
forgive your four minute laps no the
thing is if there had been a
um I wouldn't be surprised if there's a
video I mean especially with younger
Millennial attackers they're more versed
in social media now than ever and so it
makes sense that that would be the case
I know Audrey Hill was contacting people
through Instagram right before going
into the school I mean this person was
um reaching out and also being extremely
destructive to their fellow human beings
one of the pages if I'm remembering
correctly was D did I think February of
2023 and so we know that this you know
Manifesto diary whatever you want to
call it has been documenting a
developing uh motivational pattern I I
don't think this would W this was
withheld because it was implicating the
left in their radical
rhetoric I think when you look at this
you see two things as you mentioned the
the the shooter said I almost got caught
mhm and also says I'm going to be
checking
security what does this tell
us the police state the centralized
policing Authority will not be there to
protect you from these circumstances and
in fact there was a actually this was
posted on Twitter in a community notes
there's a study done in 2022 that found
34.4% of mass shootings were stopped by
a person who is legally armed and when
you remove gun-free zones from that
metric it increases to 51% of mass
shooting stopped by individuals who are
legally armed and I think the problem
here is with this Manifesto what you see
is I think we got to be careful about
the anti-white propaganda angle to this
which is important I'm not saying it's
not we should definitely call out the
the weird creepy racist leftist whatever
but also consider this is hugely
damaging to The Narrative of gun-free
zones to local politicians if the
narrative came out that gunfree zones
and and this is true everyone knows this
that gunfree zones are creating risk but
it was like the headline story Manifesto
reveals lack of security gun-free zones
and lack of FBI Integrity resulted in
this happening you're going to have
people going to their politicians be
like why did you do this so when you
look at how the FBI has you know what's
what's the fam what's the what's the
meme now was known to the FBI they say
you know it's the they do the BART meme
where it's like say the line Bart and
he's like the shooter was known to the
FBI list every time there's always an
opportunity but what happens is you get
gun control activists coming out saying
aha we must blame the guns which is a
complete distraction I don't think it is
always about gun control I think it is
about uhoh people are going to get mad
at us because we are the ones who who
created this system and made it this way
right now what you've got happening is
Democrats arguing that we should have
politicians do a thing when in reality
it's de it's it's politicians mainly
Democrats doing the thing which resulted
in the crisis in the first place and
they don't want anyone to realize that
yeah I I think that's right I think the
other aspect that's jumped out of me was
that there's a very serious anti-
elitist uh messaging throughout this
there's a specific line where he'll
writes you know those kids are awful at
their private school with their parents
expensive cars or whatever it is you
know and from what I know rep reporting
I saw from local Outlets said that hail
had attended this school and so this
behavior is bizarre in a lot of fronts
and I think now it's just a rush to spin
it as fast as possible uh I think that's
why the anti-gun narrative is going to
be so easily introduced here but it's
also important to acknowledge that this
person was deeply psychologically
Disturbed and if people knew this FBI
local law enforcement whatever they
failed the community around them it's
weird to me that the manifesto hadn't
been digitized by the perpetrator
because so often when we see events like
this part of the motive is to get it out
as fast as possible but obviously it
never been digitized because there's
spelling errors and stuff in it I mean
this is something that was like not on
the internet at all I don't think and
was just written for personal use so I
wonder what hail was thinking to seeking
to accomplish by writing down well I'll
tell you what the scary thing I think is
uh when we talk about civil conflict in
the United States I often mention that I
view the right as what I would call like
the acute threat whereas the left is the
blunt or obtuse threat The Chronic
threat you could say well it sounds so
much chronic Works acute and chronic
it's it's not it's not chronic it is
blunt
versus pointed and sharp piercing versus
bludgeoning right um acute meaning it's
extreme and it hits you hard whereas
blunt is it you know the left you get
hundreds of thousands of far-left
extremists they go around punching and
threatening people none of these rise to
a national Level news story but it's
happening all the time to the point
where you're getting shoplifting you're
getting you're getting these protesting
occupations and they bubble up sometimes
and and make the news but it's never the
most shocking story with the right you
get some deranged Lun going into a
church I shouldn't say the right but
what they what they would say is the
right what I should say is and anti-left
or um anti-government whatever you want
to call it and then as for the for the
left I think we're speaking in in in
generalities we should probably I I I
don't know if the the simplification of
left and right is is helping for anybody
because this person's clearly not a
leftist you know what I mean they're not
they're not a communist necess well they
probably are deeply influenced by it but
anyway my point is this what what what
is typically stated by the by the right
by the media as the right it's like
rarely and it and one guy a lone wolf
does some crazy crazy thing killing a
lot of people makes International
headlines and everyone says we must stop
the right they're so dangerous and it's
bad it's seriously bad it doesn't need
to be stopped however we can on the left
you have the Chaz chop protest you have
the autonomous Zone in Minneapolis you
have the Summer of Love protests you
have the 529 Insurrection all of these
things result in severe injuries and
sometimes death but what ends up
happening in the summer of love you have
mass rights across the entire country 30
people die but you don't have one person
killing 30 people right so the media
doesn't treat the story like a mass
death incident even though it was and
because of that so what's scary to me is
what we're now seeing is more left
ideologically aligned individuals
engaging in what I would describe as
acute Terror and and and violence and
extremism and when you combine the so
when you take a a left ideological bent
like this ramp the extremism up to 11
combine it with the fact that there's
hundreds of thousands of PE of these
people and they have already engaged in
Mass death incidents it's like that's
starting to get much much scarier the
right the right doesn't protest they
don't they barely ever go out you don't
see a lot of left left Wingers walking
around with ARs or assault assault
weapons so much I mean now you do at
some of these protests but this is sort
of like a new development and in and in
Seattle over the past uh probably seven
years leftists like the John Brown gun
club and the Red Guard or whatever they
call themselves they March around with
AR15s and they've even been pointing
them at vehicles and controlling traffic
saw that happen in Austin with that guy
that went to prison for defending him
want to happen to him and so what we're
starting to see over the past few years
is the left has this ubiquitous fervor
where they go out and smash things and
Destroy things and now they're adding to
their to their uh to their ranks serious
violent extremists who are engaging in I
mean this was earlier earlier in the
year and the right still doesn't have on
average any of the lowlevel terror
doesn't even have that much high level
teror I think the reality is what what
is described as the right probably is
just regular people and what is
described as the left left is an
activist base it's also this person
Audrey hail was like on some sort of
pharmaceutical is this confirmed I mean
a lot of these Mass Shooters are on some
sort of SSRI or or
pharmaceutical long I read the story but
I think that there was there was a
therapist at one point wasn't there I
mean remember I don't know for sure but
I think it's a a logical assumption
especially because SSR are widely
prescribed what's deadli an AR-15 or an
SSR it's well that's not a real there's
no real is mightier than the sword they
say that that's been quoted over long
you know the pill is mightier than the
gun warp the mind and then the the
depends on uh I would I I you know you
could theoretically argue that it is
unfair to call an AR15 deadly in any
respect right well I would say that a
gun is more is more likely to help you
commit suicide and then Sr SSRI is more
likely to help you kill a bunch of
people before you commit suicide well so
the issue is ssris could result in
complete generational collapse if you
have mind altering drug drugs being
mass-produced and mass prescribed red it
could actually destroy the fabric of of
a Nation whereas a rifle which is a
which is a a a weapon it's it's an
object intended to to be destructive
could actually help protect and defend a
nation or destroy a nation so it's
actually kind of neutral in that regard
uh either way you can say it's deadly
that's the intent of it but if the goal
of the AR is to uh actually stabilize
that is to say uh uh what do they say an
armed Society it's a polite Society you
may actually have weapons but everyone's
like you must respect other people
because they're armed and you don't want
to start a fight and that actually
simmers things down whereas mind
altering drugs can actually just make
everything go nuclear you know within a
few years yeah especially because you
don't know how people will react to them
I mean some people can take ssris for a
long time and see minimal side effects
other people uh become more unstable
because of them it's impossible to say
and that's the gamble we take in a
fically dependent Society all the
unstable people are likely to be more
likely to be prescrib them too so before
you get on it and then there's this
correlation that isn't causation exactly
I think that's a really good point
actually a lot of people are like aha
this person was on medication yeah maybe
they're trying to stop them like maybe
they were like hey maybe this is you
know that's the thing we I mean it's
very very hard to tell how people react
to medications it's not that there's
never a case for them some people
legitimately need them it's just it's a
trial and error they just give you pills
and see if it works and if they don't we
try and adjust I mean that's
unfortunately how this works I think
it's actually a really good point the
argument that aha the person was on SSRI
is it's the it's the medication is
similar to the liberal argument where
they're like ah they had a gun it's the
gun right and there are a lot of people
I think there's probably tens of
vaccinated and boosted right yeah
exactly you could you can isolate
anything figured it out now probably
probably a fair point to say there are a
lot of people who are taking ssris who
are not doing this you know I hope of
course there are I mean they're so
widely prescribed and we don't have like
this doesn't happen all the time I mean
this is tragic and part of what's what's
shocking about this is because it's it's
so unusual right she's she's a female
killer perhaps she doesn't think of
herself that way uh but a female killer
who attacks somewhere that they have
ties to I mean this is unusual for both
wh for female attackers and for school
shootings I feel like there's more of an
anonymous component a lot of times when
you get Mass Shooters like some sort of
endocrine disruption or something or
just generally like this is someone who
is behaving in a way that we don't see I
mean statistically Mass Shooters are
male and I guess I depends on how you
classify this person I hope let's let's
refocus as the conversation to the
dangers of racial Supremacy and not
white supremacy or black Supremacy or
Jewish Supremacy or Islamic like Arab
suprem it's about racial Supremacy and
how horrible it is to think of that and
to focus on that and to live in that
state of mind where you think One race
is trying to be superior like just don't
don't be a racist you can actually
extrapolate that further and just say
the real issue is any ideology that
would propose extremist solutions to
their perceived problems and so for this
individual extremist though I mean
someone willing to kill a bunch of
people to impose their political will
that makes sense now to be fair people
but they throw around a lot like if
you're abortion you're extremist you
know I can already hear the leftist
going oh so what you're saying the US
government's extremists yes yes I
am yeah when when they're when they're
blowing up kids overseas to enact their
goals and the American people
overwhelmingly say no every single time
they're asked and consistently vote for
the politician who's like no war that
being said Nikki Haley seems to be doing
well in the polls to a certain degree
but most Americans the overwheling
majority are like hey we don't want to
waste money on war so yes there are
extremists in our government willing to
kill people to get what they want thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net